fin juin la famille chapman sera
québécoise après vingt ans passés dans
la banlieue de toronto amélie qui est
née sur la rive sud de montréal veut se
rapprocher de ses parents ils vont donc
quitter leur petite maison de burlington
située à une cinquantaine de kilomètres
de toronto pour déménager ici moitié
moins loin de montréal à saint mathieu
de beloeil leur nouvelle maison sera
beaucoup plus moderne plus grande est
entouré d'un plus grand terrain ses 109
ans un support 1 million 250 mille
puis la maison qu'on a chez ac mathieu
nous a coûté un million 67 mais on
comprend pas du tout de la même maison
non plus c'est une maison qui correspond
à nos oreilles très mal
l'immobilier coûte presque deux fois
moins cher montréal qu'à toronto un
immense avantage lorsqu'on déminage
[Musique]
c'est excitant parce que je parle en
français et en anglais et les pensées au
québec et parle plus aux français alors
je connais une langue davantage s'arrête
un projet qui aurait été faisable avant
la coved mais encore beaucoup plus
facile avec la copine parce que mon
travail mais nous permet de travailler
de rester à la maison coût de la vie et
télétravail deux des facteurs qui ont
permis au québec pour la première fois
en cinquante ans de finir 2021 avec un
solde migratoire positif face à
l'ontario l'an dernier 19
1493 ontariens ont déménagé au québec
soit 787 de plus que le nombre de
québécois parti en ontario tout un
contraste avec les dernières décennies
alors que le québec perdait souvent cinq
à dix mille personnes de plus au profit
de sa voisine c'est une tendance qui
s'est amorcée depuis une simple cinq six
ans on voit que
les soldes négatifs diminue à chaque
année le québec l'économie est très
forte elle vient juste de compléter une
croissance de
6,2 pour cent en termes réels dans
l'année 2000 d'un rien le taux de
chômage est tombé à environ 4% une des
dix trous les plus baisse au canada
l'ontario ajoute marc des ormeaux vient
d'ailleurs d'enregistrer son plus grand
nombre de départs en 40 ans
108 mille personnes ont quitté l'ontario
pendant l'année civile 2021 plusieurs
jeunes décident de déménager aux autres
provinces aux provinces atlantiques la
colombie-britannique deviennent de plus
en plus attirant
[Musique]
alors ça c'est une des mes photos des
très grands projets que je vais je viens
de compléter rita light nerfs est une
photographe de toronto qui a quitté la
ville reine pour montréal l'an dernier
elle y songeait depuis longtemps et la
pandémie l'année elle aussi à faire le
grand saut j'espère que ça va aider ma
carrière absolument essayer c'est
peut-être la première
considération dans tous mes décisions
c'est ma photographie
elle se sent bien dans son grand
appartement du plateau mont royal qui
est beaucoup plus abordable qu'à toronto
économiquement et culturellement
montréal l'a séduit c'est la liberté
c'est le français c'est aussi un
m bible une vibration à montréal
différent c'est je pense que c'est plus
sociale pendant longtemps la politique a
fait fuir bien des québécois et fait
peur à bien des ontariens après
l'élection du parti québécois en 1976
par exemple pendant deux années
consécutives
le québec avait même perdu plus de 25000
résidants au profit de l'ontario et
environ 12000 après le référendum de
mais les temps ont changé
mais moi de mon côté mon mari demandé
samedi le 10 ans puis je pas certaine
que je faire tourner nécessairement
parce que c'est quelque chose qui était
beaucoup trop présent pour ma part ma
personnalité ce n'est plus une crainte
le saisit plus un facteur là non pas du
tout la personne l'ontario qui est
tellement unilingue anglophone qui a
peur du français vont pas déménagé au
québec mais
la politique au sens la peur avant la
séparation tout ça non se joue plus on
est tenant mario polèse s'attend ce
qu'il y ait désormais un meilleur
équilibre migratoires entre le québec et
l'ontario
rita les nerfs continue d'apprivoiser
montréal elle voudrait acheter un
multiplexe et il demeuré longtemps
l'avenir se vivra sans doute aussi au
québec pour la famille chapman amélie
évoque déjà l'université de ses enfants
mais il ya des choses qui ne changeront
pas
à l'origine de ce feu
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada